when I was first asked to give this
address I was filled with this enormous
sense of privilege and also in many ways
questioning myself and what it means to
be Australian because that's not the
kind of thing that you may be
consciously think about on a day-to-day
basis but it's a great source of pride
and there are so many things that we can
be delighted and pleased about and take
hold of our identity as a country which
I've reflected on as a prepare for this
address if people take away one thing
from my speech I hope it's being willing
to embrace learning of all clients for
all people and I mean that as a
representative public schools and also
as a mathematician and a mathematics
teacher and also as a parent in just a
citizen of Australia learning really is
the core of my message here today it's
why I am a teacher and delighted to be
so I'll heard that's what people take
away freedom for me Australia Day is a
wonderful time to sit up and marvel at
what a country we live in
it's a beautiful place that is peaceful
that values people and individuals and
gives opportunities to everyone no
matter where they come from or who they
are and that's what this day is about
for me
you